The answer is, sometimes it will not remove enough friends. Let's trace through
an example and talk about why. For this John example, in the for loop we start
with i is 0, i is less than the number of friends. The friend at position 0
doesn't like John, so we remove that friend. And now the indexes of the friends
change. Whereas before this was 0, 1, 2, 3. Now, it's 0, 1, 2. So we'll check
if the friend at position 1 likes John back. The person at position 1 is
Jamesha, and Jamesha does like John back. So we skip over this, and come back
up to the top of the loop. Now i is 2. So we check if friend 2 likes John back,
friend 2 does like John back so we'll come back up to the top of the loop
skipping the remove step and now i is 3 which is now less than the number of
friends so we're done but Maria never got removed. After removing TJ, Maria's
index went from 1 to 0, but the counter in the loop went from 0 to 1. So we
never checked whether Maria should be removed or not. This code will sometimes
skip friends and not check if they should be removed.